whoops fifth Harmony's normani Corday  trips on live TV  [Applause]  on Friday the band stopped by Good  Morning America to perform their new  single down but normanni couldn't keep  herself up literally it's a real  [Music]  the girls busted out some serious dance  moves on the floor but when it was time  to get up on their feet nor money  slipped and fell flat on the stage ouch  the 21 year old recovered like a pro  though later the singer had a laugh  about the on-camera spill tweeting leave  it to normanni to eat the stage  performing on at GMA the first look for  our new single hella went down down is  the first single from 5h since Camilla  Kibeho decided to part ways with the  group and go solo and it definitely  seems like they found their new group  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]